Quisiera empezar esta noche con algo completamente diferente,
pidiéndoles que me acompañen, alejándose de tierra firme
y lanzándose al océano por un momento.
90 por ciento del área habitable en el planeta está en el océano abierto,
y es donde la vida--el título de nuestro seminario esta noche--es donde comenzó la vida.
Y es un lugar vivo y encantador,
pero estamos cambiando rápidamente los océanos con nuestro--
no sólo con nuestra pesca excesiva, nuestra pesca irresponsable,
añadiendo contaminantes como los fertilizantes de nuestra tierra de cultivo.
Pero también, más recientemente, con el cambio climático,
y Steve Schneider, estoy segura, hablará con gran detalle sobre esto.
Ahora, así como continuamos manipulando sin conocimiento los océanos,
más y más informes predicen que los tipos de mares que estamos creando
propiciarán el crecimiento de animales de baja energía, como la medusa y la bacteria.
Y este puede ser el tipo de mares a los que nos encaminamos.
Ahora bien, las medusas son extrañamente hipnóticas y bellas,
y podrán ver muchas medusas magníficas en el acuario el viernes,
pero pican una barbaridad, y el sushi y sashimi de medusa
simplemente no te llenará.
Aproximadamente 100 gramos de medusa equivalen a cuatro calorías.
Así que puede ser bueno para mantener la línea,
pero probablemente no te mantendrá satisfecho por mucho tiempo.
Y un mar que solamente está lleno y rebosante de medusas
no es muy bueno para todas las demás criaturas que viven en los océanos,
es decir, a menos que se alimenten de medusas
Y este es, este voraz predador lanzando un ataque sorpresa
a esta pobre y pequeña medusa ahí desprevenida, una velero.
Y ese depredador es el pez luna gigante, el Mola mola,
cuya presa principal son las medusas.
Este animal está en el "Libro Guinness de Récords Mundiales"
por ser el pez óseo más pesado.
Alcanza casi las 5,000 libras--con una dieta a base de medusas, principalmente.
Y pienso que en cierto modo esta es una bonita coincidencia cosmológica,
que el Mola mola--su nombre común en español es pez luna-- en inglés literal -pez sol-
que su comida favorita sea la medusa luna.
Así que es bonito, que el sol y la luna se unan de esta forma,
aunque uno se esté comiendo al otro.
Ahora, así es como normalmente puedes ver un pez luna,
esto es por lo que ellos toman su nombre (en inglés).
Les gusta tomar el sol, no puedo culparlos.
Sencillamente flotan en la superficie del mar
la mayoría de la gente piensa que están enfermos o son flojos, pero este es un comportamiento típico,
se recuestan y toman el sol en la superficie.
Su otro nombre, Mola mola es--suena Hawaiano,
pero en realidad viene del latín que quiere decir piedra de molino,
y eso es atribuible a su forma redondeada, muy rara, cortada.
Es como si, a medida que iban creciendo, se les olvidó la parte de la cola.
Y eso es precisamente lo que me atrajo hacia el Mola en primer lugar,
fue esa forma terriblemente rara.
Saben, uno mira a los tiburones, y son aerodinámicos, y son elegantes,
y uno mira los atunes, y son como torpedos--
simplemente dan a conocer su plan. Ellos son migración y fuerza,
y luego uno mira al pez luna.
(Risas)
Y este es simplemente elegantemente misterioso, es simplemente--
realmente como que esconde sus cartas un poco mejor que digamos, el atún.
Así que yo estaba intrigada con--ustedes saben, con ¿cuál es la historia de este animal?
Bueno, así como cualquier cosa en biología, nada tiene sentido realmente,
excepto a la luz de la evolución.
El Mola no es la excepción.
Ellos aparecieron un poco después de que los dinosaurios desaparecieran,
hace 65 millones de años, en una época en la que las ballenas todavía tenían patas,
y proceden de un grupo de pequeños y rebeldes peces globo-
permítanme ahora contar una pequeña historia de forma Kiplinesca.
Por supuesto la evolución es de alguna manera al azar, y saben,
aproximadamente hace 55 millones de años existía este pequeño y rebelde grupo de peces globo
que dijeron, oh, al diablo con los arrecifes de coral---
vamos a ir a alta mar.
Y muchas generaciones, muchos pellizcos y torsiones,
y convertimos a nuestro pez globo en Mola.
Saben, si le dan suficiente tiempo a la Madre Naturaleza, esto es lo que ella producirá.
Se ven---tal vez se ven
un poco como prehistóricos y sin terminar, tal vez reducidos,
pero de hecho, de hecho son los--
compiten por la primera posición de los peces más evolucionado-derivados en el mar,
junto con el lenguado.
Son---cada cosa de ese pez ha sido cambiada.
Y en términos de peces---
los peces aparecieron hace 500 millones de años, y son bastante modernos,
hace solamente 50 millones de años, así que--
así que de modo interesante, revelan su ascendencia a medida que se desarrollan.
Empiezan siendo pequeños huevos,
y están otra vez en el "Libro Guinness de Récords Mundiales"
por tener el mayor número de huevos de cualquier vertebrado en el planeta.
Una sola hembra de cuatro pies tuvo 300 millones de huevos,
puede cargar 300 millones de huevos en sus ovarios--imaginen--
y llegan a medir 10 pies de largo. Imaginen lo que tiene uno de 10 pies.
Y de ese pequeño huevo.
pasan por esta fase de pequeño y espinudo pez puercoespín, evocando a sus ancestros,
y se desarrollan--esta es su etapa adolescente.
De adolescentes nadan en bancos, y de adultos se convierten en enormes solitarios.
Ese es un pequeño buceador ahí en la esquina.
Están en el "Libro Guinness de Récords Mundiales, de nuevo
por ser el campeón mundial en crecimiento de los vertebrados.
Desde su tamaño de incubación en el huevo, hasta su etapa de larva
hasta que alcanzan la edad adulta, incrementan 600 millones de veces su peso.
600 millones. Ahora imaginen que ustedes dan a luz a un bebito,
y tuvieran que alimentar esta cosa.
Eso querría decir que su hijo, esperarían que ganara el peso de seis Titanics.
Ahora bien, no sé cómo alimentarían a un niño como ese pero--
no sabemos qué tan rápido los Molas crecen en estado natural,
pero los estudios sobre crecimiento en captividad en el Acuario de la Bahía de Monterrey--
uno de los primeros lugares en tenerlos en captividad--
ellos tuvieron uno que ganó 800 libras en 14 meses.
Yo dije, bueno , ese es un verdadero Americano.
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
De modo que ser un solitario es una gran cosa, especialmente en los mares de hoy
porque nadar en bancos solía ser la salvación para los peces,
pero ahora es suicidio para los peces.
Pero desafortunadamente los Molas, a pesar de que no nadan en bancos,
todavía quedan atrapados en las redes como pesca accidental.
Si vamos a salvar al mundo de la dominación total de las medusas,
entonces tenemos que pensar lo que los predadores de medusas--
cómo viven sus vidas, como el Mola.
Y desafortunadamente, ellos forman una gran parte de la pesca accidental de California--
hasta un 26 por ciento de la red de arrastre.
Y en el Mediterráneo, en la pesca de pez espada con red,
forman hasta el 90 por ciento.
De forma que debemos averigüar cómo están viviendo sus vidas.
¿Y cómo se hace eso?
Cómo se hace eso con un animal--muy pocos lugares en el mundo.
Este es una criatura del océano abierto. No conoce fronteras--no va a tierra firme.
¿Cómo puede uno comprender?
¿Cómo seduce uno a una criatura del océano como esa para que cuente sus secretos?
Bueno, hay una nueva y grandiosa tecnología
que acaba de volverse accesible,
y precisamente es un beneficio para comprender a los animales del océano.
Y se puede ver justo aquí. Esa pequeña etiqueta ahí arriba.
Esa pequeña etiqueta puede grabar temperatura, profundidad e intensidad de la luz,
lo que se correlaciona con el tiempo, y gracias a eso podemos obtener la localización.
Y puede grabar esta información hasta por dos años,
y guardarla en esa etiqueta, liberarla en un tiempo previamente programado,
flotar a la superficie, cargar toda esa información, la narración completa del viaje,
al satélite, que la transmite directamente a nuestras computadoras,
y tendremos toda esa información. Y ni siquiera tuvimos que--
sólo tuvimos que etiquetar al animal y regresar a casa y saben, a sentarnos en nuestros escritorios.
Así que la gran cosa del Mola
es que cuando les ponemos una etiqueta--si ven aquí arriba--
va siguiendo la corriente, ahí es justo donde pusimos la etiqueta.
Y justamente ocurre que ese es un parásito pegado al Mola.
Los Molas tienen la mala reputación de cargar con toneladas de parásitos.
Ellos simplemente son hoteles de parásitos, incluso sus parásitos tienen parásitos.
Creo que Donne escribió un poema sobre eso.
Pero ellos tienen 40 especies de parásitos,
y así pues supusimos que un parásito más no sería mucho problema.
Y resulta que ellos son un muy buen vehículo para transportar equipo oceanográfico.
Hasta ahora, no parece importarles.
Así que, ¿qué estamos intentando averigüar? Nos hemos enfocado en el Pacífico.
Estamos etiquetando en la costa de California, y estamos etiquetando en Taiwan y Japón.
Y estamos interesados en cómo estos animales están usando las corrientes,
usando la temperatura, usando el océano, para vivir sus vidas.
Nos encantaría etiquetar en Monterrey.
Monterrey es uno de los pocos lugares en el mundo donde los Molas llegan en grandes números.
No en esta época del año--es más alrededor de Octubre.
Y nos encantaría etiquetar aquí--esta es una toma aérea de Monterrey--
pero desafortunadamente, los Molas aquí terminan viéndose así.
Porque a otro de nuestros vecinos del lugar le gustan los Molas pero no en el buen sentido.
El león marino de California agarra los Molas tan pronto como ellos entran a la bahía,
les quita las aletas, los modela como un grandioso frisbee, estilo mola,
y luego los zarandea de un lado a otro.
Y no estoy exagerando, es simplemente--
y algunas veces no se los comen, es francamente malévolo.
Y saben, los vecinos del lugar piensan que es un comportamiento terrible,
es simplemente horrible ver que esto pase, día tras día,
Los pobres pequeños Molas llegando, siendo despedazados,
de modo que nos dirigimos hacia el sur, a San Diego.
Aquí abajo no hay tantos leones marinos de California.
Y los Molas ahí, los puedes encontrar fácilmente con un avión para localizar bancos de peces,
y les gusta estar debajo de masas flotantes de algas marinas.
Y debajo de esas algas marinas--esto es por lo que los Molas vienen aquí
porque es la hora del spa para los Molas aquí.
Tan pronto como ellos se colocan bajo esa masa flotante de algas marinas, los peces limpiadores exfoliantes vienen.
Y vienen y les dan a los Molas--
pueden ver que ellos se colocan en esta chistosa posición que dice,
"No estoy amenazando, pero necesito un masaje."
(Risas)
Y pondrán sus aletas hacia afuera y sus ojos en blanco,
y los peces vienen y limpian, limpian, limpian--
porque los Molas, saben, son un restaurante de parásitos.
Y también es un buen lugar para ir al sur
porque el agua es más tibia, y los Molas son como más amistosos ahí abajo.
Quiero decir qué otro tipo de pez, si uno se acerca de buen modo,
diría, "Ok, ráscame justo aquí."
Uno verdaderamente puede nadar hacia un Mola, son tan gentiles,
y si uno se acerca de buena forma, puede rascarlos y ellos lo disfrutan.
De manera que hemos etiquetado una parte del Pacífico,
hemos ido a otra parte del Pacífico,
y hemos etiquetado en Taiwan, y en Japón.
Y también en estos lugares, los Molas caen en las redes colocadas a lo largo de estos países.
Y no son devueltos como desperdicio, se comen.
Nos sirvieron una comida de nueve platos de Mola después de que etiquetamos.
Bueno, no el que etiquetamos!
Y todo desde el riñón, hasta las conchas, hasta la espina dorsal,
hasta el músculo de la aleta hasta--creo que casi todo el pez-- es comido.
Así que la parte más difícil de etiquetar, ahora, es
después de que pones la etiqueta, debes esperar, meses.
Y uno se esta preguntando, oh, espero que el pez esté bien,
Yo espero, yo espero que sea capaz de vivir realmente su vida
durante el tiempo que la etiqueta está grabando.
Las etiquetas cuestan 3500 dólares cada una, y el tiempo de satélite son otros 500 dólares,
así que estás como, oh, espero que la etiqueta esté bien.
Y entonces la espera es realmente la parte más difícil.
Les voy a enseñar nuestra información más reciente.
Y no ha sido publicada, así que es información totalmente secreta sólo para TED.
Y al enseñarles esto, saben, cuando vemos esta información,
estamos pensando, oh ¿será que estos animales, será que cruzan el ecuador?
¿Ellos van de un lado al otro del Pacífico?
Y hemos descubierto que ellos son en cierta forma hogareños.
No migran mucho. Este es su trayecto:
desplegamos la etiqueta en la costa de Tokyo, y el Mola en un mes,
más o menos se metió en la corriente Kuroshio en la costa del Japón, y estuvo merodeando ahí.
Y después de cuatro meses subió, saben, por la costa al norte de Japón.
Y esa es más o menos la extensión de su hábitat.
Ahora bien, eso es importante, sin embargo, porque si hay mucha presión pesquera,
la población no se renueva.
De modo que es una información importante.
Pero también lo que es importante es que no son peces perezosos.
Son muy activos.
Y este es un día en la vida de un Mola, y si nosotros--
van de arriba para abajo, y arriba y abajo, y arriba abajo, y arriba
y arriba y abajo, hasta 40 veces al día.
Al salir el sol, ven en el azul, empiezan a bucear.
Abajo--y a medida que el sol brilla más se van cada vez más hondo, más hondo.
Sondean las profundidades hasta 600 metros, en temperaturas hasta un grado centígrado,
y esto es por lo que uno los ve en la superficie--está tan frío allá abajo.
Tienen que salir a la superficie, calentarse, recibir esa energía solar,
y luego sumergirse de nuevo en las profundidades, y van arriba y abajo y arriba y abajo.
Y están tocando una capa allá abajo, se llama la capa oscura
en esa capa hay toda una variedad de alimento.
Así que más que solamente ser un haragán tomando el sol,
son peces realmente muy activos, que bailan este baile alocado
entre la superficie y el fondo y a través de la temperatura.
Vemos el mismo patrón--ahora con estas etiquetas
estamos viendo un patrón similar para los peces espada, mantarrayas, atunes,
un verdadero juego tridimensional.
Esto es parte de un programa mucho más grande llamado El Censo de la Vida Marina,
donde serán etiquetados por todo el mundo
y el Mola va a ser parte de eso.
Y lo que es emocionante--todos ustedes viajan, y saben
lo mejor de viajar es poder encontrar a los lugareños,
y encontrar los buenos lugares al obtener el conocimiento local.
Bueno, ahora con el Censo de la Vida Marina, podremos acercarnos a los locales
y explorar el 90 por ciento de nuestra área habitable, con conocimiento local.
Nunca hubo--nunca hubo un tiempo tan emocionante, o tan vital para ser una bióloga.
Lo que me lleva a mi último punto, y es lo que pienso es lo más divertido.
Hice un website porque estaba recibiendo muchas preguntas sobre los Molas y peces luna.
Y entonces se me ocurrió que respondería a las preguntas,
y podría dar las gracias a mis patrocinadores, como National Geographic y Lindbergh.
Pero la gente escribía en la página toda clase de--
toda clase de historias sobre animales,
y queriendo ayudarme a conseguir muestras para análisis genético.
Y lo que encontré más emocionante es que todos tenían un--
un amor compartido y un interés en los océanos.
Estaba recibiendo informes de monjas católicas,
Rabinos judíos, Musulmanes, Cristianos--todos escribían,
unidos por su amor a la vida.
Y para mi eso--No creo que pueda decirlo con mejores palabras que el inmortal poeta:
"Un toque de la naturaleza une al mundo."
Y claro, puede que simplemente sea un pez viejo, tonto y grande, pero está ayudando.
Si está ayudando a unir al mundo, pienso que definitivamente es el pez del futuro.